okay if you didn't know big Harry Potter
fan here I love the movies I love the
books even more I read all the books in
less than two weeks so please keep that
love and want for love in mind as I
review cash grab the grime of grundle
wad
[Music]
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald the crimes of Grindelwald is
chapter 2 of the Harry Potter prequel
series first one being fantastic beasts
and where to find them now fantastic
beasts crimes of Grindelwald but not a
lot of beasts what aren't they're gonna
keep calling it fantastic beasts because
the beasts of seem too important this
point what is Johnny Depp plays
Grindelwald Grindelwald is going after
Ezra Miller's character Creedence we
know that because a roomful of people
actually tell you that that's how you
find out just a room full of people
vomiting exposition nothing more organic
than a bunch of people just telling you
the plot so now Newt Scamander and his
friends are trying to stop Grindelwald
and Grindelwald is trying to go after
credence for some Clearwater Revival and
this movie is mostly and for the most
part aimless as [ __ ] for the life of me
I could barely tell you the plot of this
movie other than good guys going after
bad guys bad guys going after someone
else it's full of characters I don't
really care about I wanted to care about
them in fantastic beasts and where to
find them and I did I kind of latched
onto him there but then some of their
stories ended and in this one they're
back come the dialogue for that
explanation is I thought we wiped her
memories like are you tried but it
didn't work okay yes it didn't work
welcome back where this movie is most
interesting is also one of the
frustrating elements of his movie this
movie's most interesting when you see
the tie-ins and easter eggs to the harry
potter story that you know that said
that's always fun to have in a movie
like this but i should be icing on the
cake the cake that should be a solid
structure but it's asked backwards it's
not icing on the cake the cake is on the
icing you're using those Easter eggs
that icing as the foundation of the cake
and it's just a soggy mess you know I
love my food metaphor Jude Law is great
as a younger Dumbledore Johnny Depp as
great as Grindelwald by far he's the
best part of this movie we've already
seen the villain who's gonna outdo this
guy that said as this guy is here he's
entertaining as hell oh really this
movie comes across as boring and
lifeless it's a boring lifeless showcase
of spells the spells are cool the
creatures are cool but that's the point
of this movie it's just a showcase of
Wizarding world's shed the entire plot
of this movie can be condensed into a
half an hour episode of a Harry Potter
show it lacks the focus that the Harry
Potter stories have maybe that's because
Harry Potter was really confined to a
school for the most part but undeniably
that helps the plot out you're in one
place you're getting to the end of the
year as the end of the year is coming
well you know the evils ramping up their
threats getting more real by the end of
the school year the threats here they've
got to deal with it this is just all
over the place this person is looking
for this person they're over here then
they go to this country over there bolt
grouped with multiple motivations it
lacks focus and as much as some of the
Easter eggs are cool the other Easter
eggs are there to expand the Laura like
Nagini is a person yeah Voldemort's
snake was a person the person turns into
a snake and then there's snake I don't
need to know that I don't care to know
that why can't Nagini just be his pet no
human being is as loyal as a pet like
Voldemort trusted in a guinea more than
any person around him that's what I
liked about it now Nagini is a person
which means when the guinea eats people
it's kind of gross granted it makes it
kind of darker did another Longbottom
know he decapitated a person I just
don't need to know that Nagini was a
person any more than I needed to know
that people's connection to the forest
was through bacteria in their cells in
fact new guinea in this movie is kind of
a point I'm trying to make here new
guinea in this movie is not interesting
has no development whatsoever there's no
real character whatsoever the coolest
thing about her character is that she is
an animal from the original Harry Potter
movies that we know that's the only
reason you even give a [ __ ] about Nagini
in here if Nagini wasn't Nagini if
Nagini was an original character you'd
be like why is that generic as character
in here like why do we care who is that
guys in the end the last part of the
last act of the crimes of Grindelwald
that was interesting is our way of
seeing Voldemort's rise without actually
seeing Voldemort rise because
Grindelwald is not Voldemort and by the
time we saw Voldemort in the Harry
Potter series it was the years after he
gained his following so now we see how
someone like that can gain their
following in the Wizarding World I think
that's cool and where it leaves off it
leaves off to where the third movie
could be a really interesting tale an
interesting tale that might render the
first two useless I don't know I just
wasn't feeling this I felt none of the
magic just a series of Easter eggs and
throw backs that are supposed to appease
fans in the end I feel like fans just
want a better story if you can't think
of a better story maybe we shouldn't go
back to the Wizarding World
the characters were hollowed the
relationships between them were light
the plots convoluted is how like they're
just trying to fill in time if just
seeing Easter eggs and tie-ins to things
you know in the Wizarding World is
enough then I think I'll probably have a
good time with his memory if you require
more than that you probably won't in the
end I'm just not gonna remember this one
at t-minus one day yeah I've already
forgot in his movie you see a lot of
spells but you don't feel any magic feel
free to put that on the blu-ray box well
I still got the Harry Potter movies
nothing could take that from us alright
so fantastic cash grab the grime of
grundle wad have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]